simone veil bonjour je vous présente
florence belkacem qui interviewait avec
moi est ce que vous connaissez les amis
le bout je les connais par la télévision
pierre nebout cécilia n'aura richard
burgi chars et francis lalanne que vous
avez vus à ramatuelle
absolument est-ce que devant vous on
peut allumer une cigarette
enfin on a mis ça arrive souvent ça
arrive ça arrive souvent et je ne suis
pas du tout une terroriste en la matière
ce que je crois c'est que aujourd'hui il
ya tout de même une campagne contre le
tabagisme et où les médecins ont
justement demandé qu'on évite de fumer à
la télévision alors c'est pas moins de
sa gêne mais c'est je dirais dans le
cadre de cette action pédagogique que je
crois qu'on peut faire un effort je vais
faire un effort jusqu'à la fin que
c'était la revue je ne fais moi peur
c'est non je crois que ça donne vraiment
c'est une des choses sur lesquelles les
médecins disent que le plus c'est
l'image était donné
à la télévision justement par des gens
comme vous célèbre qui sont les idoles
des jeunes souvent et bien le fait
le fait de fumer c'est certainement une
image qui est en réalité très positif
pour le tabac est donc faux une
incitation vous avez commandé un perrier
alors comme ça vous ne venez pas
d'exemple d'alcoolisme mobile non on
n'est pas alcoolique parce que parce que
l'on boit une coupe de champagne ça vous
pencher ce soir d'avoir brisé
je préfère prendre un verre d'eau mais
je le sabbat ya vraiment une question
d'image
le deuxième tour
monsieur bart pour être élu est obligé
de prendre les voix de le pen est ce que
vous lui demanderez de prendre une
position publique
je crois que même dès le premier tour il
est tout à fait souhaitable que toutes
les personnalités candidat aux élections
présidentielles se situe très clairement
par rapport aux idées de monsieur le pen
et par rapport à ce que représente le
front national
cela dit qu'est ce que ça veut dire
prendre le deuxième tour les voix de
monsieur le pen quand vous votez les
bulletins de vote ne porte pas un petit
signe qui montre que ce sont des voix
qui viennent de tel ou tel de tel ou tel
type des lecteurs d'abord je suis
convaincu qu'au premier tour
il ya des gens qui voteront aux extrêmes
je dirais aussi bien d'ailleurs
pour madame
guillaume par une espèce de vote de
refus ce qui d'ailleurs est en soi déjà
une façon de manifester et je trouve
toujours préoccupant qu'il y ait des
gens qui choisissent les extrêmes par
vote de refus des candidats
je peux classe immédiatement votre
risque d'être élue avec les voix de le
pen mais vous ne serez pas vous ne serez
pas on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui il
y a une grande partie des électeurs de
monsieur le pen qui viennent qui vient
du parti communiste même du parti
socialiste et de la gauche toutes les
études qui ont été faites dans les
toutes les études qui ont été faites
dans certaines villes où il ya un fort
pourcentage de
revoir sur le candidat de monsieur le
pen sont des quartiers où il y avait des
bois de rose très importante donc on
peut absolument prendre dit regarde tel
pourcentage ou telle voie viennent jouer
nationale
meetic est très important en revanche
cessé de se démarquer très clairement
que de ma directrice
excusez moi comme tous les gens comme
tous les hommes politiques de la droite
libérale des gens qui disent nous on
fait bien la différence entre le pen les
électeurs devant moi je dis pas je fais
la différence entre les électeurs et
monsieur le pen absolument pas c'est pas
du tout le discours jeu que je tiens je
dis simplement qu'on ne peut pas savoir
jeudi plus je dis d'abord c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre d électeurs non
plus partagent pas tous les sentiments
et les idées de monsieur le pen c'était
bien il ya une grande partie de rejet et
donc il faut bien voir les raisons de ce
de ce rejet
ce que je dis simplement c'est une un
constat si vous voulez maternelle qui
fait qu'au moment où les gens votent
on ne sait pas quel est le 3e débat
raymond barre ça devient des bons
gabarits mais les bons libéraux mais
c'est pas que ça vient des banlieues
c'est que vous n'avez pas le moyen vous
n'avez pas le moyen de savoir si ces 5%
10%
ça serait avait amené les condors en
général et au doux nom apparaît souvent
bouclé à temps plein au premier
on a tenté une expérience hier c'était
la fête le blanc rouge justement parce
que cette question nous importe c'est à
dire que 1 électeurs de le pen au
premier tour devient un électeur libéral
ou deuxième et on a demandé à notre ami
philippe guérin ici présents neil et
hier la fête du front national a fait le
blanc rouge pour demander aux militants
du front pour toute notre aide
non ce qu'il pensait de vous ce qu'il
pensait des gens de la droite où on va
regarder le sujet on va regarder le
sujet